begin with some very sad news in akron
ohio where newly released video of
police killing a black man has led to
angry protests throughout the city
jaylen walker was shot more than 60
times after an attempted traffic stop a
week ago the video is very very
difficult to watch police say the
traffic stop escalated after the 25 year
old drove away and a shot was fired from
the car the deadly shooting followed a
roughly six-minute pursuit walker was
unarmed when he was killed elise preston
is in akron for us this morning elise
good morning
vlad good morning to you the tension is
palpable here in the community as
walker's family calls for both
accountability and peace akron's mayor
canceled fourth of july events saying
this is not a time for a city-led invest
city-led celebration meanwhile the
police chief and other government
officials say they understand the
outrage after the release of video they
call extremely
disturbing newly released police body
camera footage shows the critical
moments leading up to the death of jalen
walker
police say they were attempting to stop
walker for a traffic and equipment
violation which was not seen on camera
seconds later
the officer reports a gunshot fired from
walker's car that vehicle just had a
shot come out of its door it went from
being
a routine traffic stop
to now a public safety issue
video shows walker then leading police
on a chase before he eventually jumps
out of the passenger side wearing a ski
mask officers tried to deploy a taser
while chasing him on foot but are
unsuccessful moments later eight
officers unleashed dozens of rounds
[Applause]
officers say they tried to render aid
but walker who was unarmed at the time
of the shooting died at the scene police
say a handgun and a magazine were found
in walker's car and that body camera
images show walker appearing to reach
for his waist area right before he was
killed but he did not fire at police
during the foot pursuit a preliminary
medical report says walker had more than
60 gunshot wounds
they need to be able to articulate
what specific threats they were facing
and that goes for every round that goes
down the barrel of their gun it was
absolutely excessive the law requires to
use force that is reasonable
protests continue late sunday where
demonstrators say police used tear gas
to disperse the crowd akron police have
not confirmed those reports walker's
family is calling for calm in a
statement they said jalen would have
wanted us to channel our anger into
peaceful thoughtful action that can
bring long-term change and reform
it does help with all of the
transparency with the early releases but
the transparency
does not
does not camouflage the pain
of what happened
the eight officers have been placed on
administrative leave pending an
independent investigation an independent
state investigation the police union
representing those eight officers
involved says it believes the
investigation will show that the
officer's actions were justified
including the number of shots fired ed
elise it's another one of those rough
stories we thank you and your team
though for being there for us